you
this was in the year nineteen
fifty-seven when the Russians sent up
the first satellite which they called
Sputnik which means companion it was a
companion for the earth so this but Nick
was up there in space and it was making
everybody nervous because if the
Russians could send satellites into
space they could also throw missiles at
us and we at that time didn't have any
missiles which we can throw at them so
it was a scary moment and so it was a
moment when you could get money very
easily for crazy projects and so my
friend Ted Taylor who was a young
physicist to actually younger than me he
had this idea of building a spaceship
with nuclear bombs which sounds crazy
and in a certain way it is crazy but it
could have actually it could have worked
and so I thought that would be exciting
to do I have no done anything like that
I'd been always just a mathematician and
working on paper but so that gave me a
chance to do something real so I moved
to San Diego in California and joined
the company called general atomic which
is still there and went to work on the
spaceship and it looked so we might even
get the green light actually to go ahead
and build it but in the end of course we
didn't the fatal flaw of that whole
scheme is that it spreads radioactivity
all around you're exploding bombs in big
numbers so you really do make a
tremendous mess and so in the end common
sense prevailed and they decided to go
ahead with ordinary rockets not with
nuclear bombs but
we had a great time we studied the
theory of this and the engineering we
had a lot of good engineers and we
actually did little tests of chemical
explosives building little model plane
little model spacecraft which would go
pop pop pop pop just up in the sky and
come down again and just to show that we
knew how to do it so we had every
Saturday morning way we didn't get paid
for that but every Saturday morning we'd
go and fly our little models the rest of
the week we'd do the serious stuff so I
spent a year and a half there and the
project actually lasted for seven years
but by the end of the first year it was
pretty clear that it wasn't going to fly
if it had been given the green light we
could have gone to Mars in about five
years I mean the thing started in 58 and
we planned to have a Mars mission
already after within five years and we
be scooting all around the solar system
it was a very very high performance ship
far better than anything we have today
and it would have easily gone to Mars
and back and to Jupiter and the
satellites of Saturn and all the
interesting places in the solar system
we could have gone scooting around and
of course we intended to go ourselves
this was a big ship and it was with a
crew we imagined we would have a crew of
about 40 people so it was on the grand
scale and it would have been
comparatively cheap because it it was
built like a submarine not like an
airplane was a heavy engineering and and
so a lot cheaper than aerospace
well the joke is of course that we do
such marvelous missions now with small
payloads when we worked on Orion we were
talking about a thousand tons of payload
just for one ship and so we thought of
ourselves sort of like like the Darwin
on the Beagle going out for five years
and with all our provisions and having
taken longer squash courts earth so that
you could stay fit and we could take a
law all most anything you wanted and of
course nowadays the whole way of
operating in space is so totally
different now you measure the payloads
in pounds not in tons and so we have a
ship which is now orbiting around Saturn
called cassini which of course doesn't
have people on board it has wonderful
instruments on board and that the the
total payload of that thing is a few
thousand pounds and it's doing far more
exploring them we could have done so if
we had a thousand tons of payload today
we wouldn't know what to do with it
oh yes I think so but of course my guess
is no better than anybody else's but
technically it could be done of course
it's much too expensive just for the
next hundred years or maybe the next
thousand years but we have lots and lots
of time so I would imagine that we will
be scooting around on a much grander
scale but but it could on the other hand
we could decide we're not interested so
let's let's not do it and that remains
to be seen